All right, guys. We're finally here.
We're catching up
with the Chad Nicholas D'Orio fallout.
Okay, I haven't covered it. So, way late
to it.
But, Chad leaked the tea party group
chat. Obviously, Chad was previously
leaked by Salvo
in a big drama that they all cried
about.
Right, Keemstar's crying about this one
in private, too.
So, um
we're going to take a look. Chad's
leaked these messages. Uh apparently,
Nick D'Orio was crying like a total
about his sweeping comments. Just
desperately trying to rally his
commentary friends to
hate Chad with him.
So, let's see. Let's take a look.
Now, I think me and Nicholas have done
having a conversation about it, and
that's that, okay? But, it turns out
Nicholas isn't quite done yet, okay?
Nicholas is not He's got some more gas
in the tank about this topic. He goes
>> [laughter]
>> And this is where I get in trouble,
guys. The tea party group chat. Nicholas
goes to the tea party group chat and
continues to complain about this.
Oh my god, bro. It is like I think okay,
me and Nicholas is done talking about
this. But, then I notice some messages
in the tea party group chat. Now, here's
the thing. It isn't really posted in
that much anymore to be perfectly honest
with you. And at this point, I'm just
losing it a bit. I'm like, "Oh my god,
dude. Really? We've got to have round
Ding ding, round three." You know,
whatever [laughter] the [__] it is.
Oh my god, dude. What the
So, then he starts posting the most
passive-aggressive
schmitch ever, okay? After everything
we've spoken about, he's going at it
again, passive-aggressive, okay?
I'm going to go over it tonight on
stream. The girls definitely need time
and people have cooperated certain
stuff, but I think the bulk of the
series is unproven.
Just remember, if you don't have a video
prepped by 8:00 a.m. on Thursday
morning, you're already sweeping and
and a sound [__] So, I see this
and I'm like, "Okay.
Whatever. He wants to have a little bit
of a bit a little bit of a This is gay.
Whatever. And this channel is going to
use the machine watch probably going to
displate quite quickly, okay?
Lol, yep, I saw that.
Augie, wow, dude.
>> Dude, I what is Ali? Why even type this?
Like what a nasty
dick pick me hag.
It's like so sickening.
Haha, yeah, so true, Nick.
Sweeping in with yourself, lol.
And then
no, dude.
I love baselessly having an audience
swung into me. It's so fun.
OH MY
GOD, THIS GUY IS such a
He's so sensitive. It's unreal, bro. I'm
like, here we go again. Here we go
again. Ding ding, round [__] three.
Here we go again. [laughter] What the
[__] ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THIS? BUT NO,
apparently not. Apparently, we need to
keep [__] talking about it, bro.
And I say, "Haha, bro, stop being such a
whiny ass lover. Oh my [__] god,
dude.
>> thanks. I'm at my wit's end, though.
Thanks. I've already said he might cover
it on my stream. I put out a tweet. That
isn't actually about Nicholas at that
point. I am talking about other channels
and still he's bagging on about this,
dude. It is [__] ridiculous. Holy
[__] man. Not everything is about you,
dude.
Don't you think it's [__] crazy that
zero big commentary channels have
covered this?
Not a single daily commentary channel
has picked this story up.
So, I'm making it really clear from the
start that I am talking about other
things as well as Nicholas. I know that
there's been this kind of like
misunderstanding or people
>> Yeah, I can't be bothered to pick
through um all the arguments about you
know, sweeping and why certain channels
didn't cover what certain days. I
thought I've gone over that in every
other piece of Chud coverage on this on
this drama.
You can see that in other places, guys.
You can see that in other places. I'm
not going to pick through all right now.
I'm just going to laugh at
Nick Fuentes crying about it, okay? Cuz
I just don't I honestly don't remember
all the arguments.
It's been like 2 weeks since I spoke
about it. So, I just don't
I just don't care to. It's just not that
interesting to me.
>> was saying that I'm a snake.
When I
>> Sleepy swept, that's true. That's facts.
Never forget that Sleepy swept. spoke
about it on stream and said the big
sweep might be on. Sure, that's a
reference to Nicholas. It turned out I
ended up covering it. I was too soon to
say that on the stream. I then move on
to talking about other people not
talking about it, and Nicholas still
wants to find a way to make it about
him. It is never-ending, dude. It's
never-ending. Not a single daily
commentary channel has picked the story
up. And then they share my tweet and
they ask, "Who am I referring to?"
"Just curious." And I say, "You, Augie."
Obviously, as a joke.
You talked to Augie who reported he's on
vacation, by the way. Lol. Okay.
To be fair, he said what I told him.
Lol. I am traveling for a couple of days
right now.
Sensitive Satori, Briana, More Pegasus,
West Chat. So, just some names off the
top of my head of the kinds of channels
that haven't picked this up, okay?
Say their names, then.
Can we take a moment to check in on the
states with this video Max Blumenthal
posted of a marine refusing to fight for
Israel?
Uh maybe.
Wait. Okay, I will briefly get into the
argument, I guess.
Because this tweet that Chud put out the
next day after making the comments,
this was like a walk back. This was like
making it less about Nick.
And obviously so.
But that's still not enough for Nick.
He's like,
"Say their names then, because your chat
only sees me.
Your chat your chat your chat." See,
there it was such projection that the
whole stream where he's saying,
"Chud's terrified of his chat. Chud's
terrified of Perry.
Chud's terrified of Dickers."
It's like so [__] stupid, dude. And I
say, "You, Augie, obviously, as a joke."
You talked to Augie, who reportedly is
on vacation, by the way, lol. Okay?
To be fair, he said what I told him,
lol. "I am traveling for a couple of
days right now."
Sensitive Satori, Breon, more Pegasus
West Jet. So, just some names off the
top of my head of the kinds of channels
that haven't picked this up, okay?
"Say their names then.
Name a daily slop channel, because your
chat only sees me, lol." Sorry,
Nicholas. Who's afraid of chat again?
Who is it that's afraid of chat? You're
there quivering in the tea party group
chat, right? Worried that my chat is
only going to see you, and I'm the one
that's afraid of chat, you [__]
[__] You [__] [__] bro. What a
[__] pathetic coward, man. Sat there
acting all [__] tough on his stream
with his dry [__] mouth and his
little god,
sweating like [__] knowing that I'm not
on [__] Odd Day anymore, okay? And
I'm here to [__] respond to your
[__]
And here you are weeks ago, "Ooh, but
your chat is ONLY GOING TO SEE ME, you
[__] [__] Get [__] bro. Get
[__]
Your drooling audience is going to go,
'Oh, this doesn't mean anything. This
doesn't mean anything.' Yes, it [__]
does, bro. I'm [__] ex-
>> Yeah, it does. It doesn't make any sense
each other when terrified of his chat or
whatever the [__] And um
here's Nick literally saying it plainly.
Saying it plainly.
And it's so obvious that Nick lies about
this stuff. We've proven Nick lies about
this stuff before.
Cuz obviously in public Nick would say
"Um the only reason we terrified of DGG
is if you're some [__] like Kelly
Jean." And then private Sunday is like,
"Oh, I don't want DGG going after me."
Exposing that you're the one that's
terrified of chat actually, not [__]
me. You're the one sat there complaining
to me that my chat is going to see you.
Because I've not made it clear enough
that it's not about you. And it isn't
actually about you. It's very clear when
you read the tweet that it's not about
Nicholas cuz I talked
>> terrified of being humiliated. Yeah,
it's very much like uh you know
he clearly didn't he didn't get fat as
an adult.
You know.
They grew up that way.
Chat isn't afraid of Perry. It's more of
a disgust response.
Thank you for the 699 Josh. Thank you.
Yeah, clearly grew up that way. Clearly
grew up um
very overweight.
And it shows.
about the daily slop channels
in the tweet. Because you know what? I
am trying to make it clear that there
are bigger people here than [__]
Nicholas and Augie that are not picking
the story up. And still he's trying to
make it about himself. He's trying to
make it about himself again cuz he's a
[__] total [__] bro. And he cannot
see past Yeah, like maybe it's from
getting hazed at the frat. Getting he
like you got hazed joining the frat.
Maybe that's what it is. So that could
make sense. And he's quivering that my
tweet doesn't say, "This is not about
Nicholas Diorio by the way." [__] me,
dude. Oh, sorry, dude. I'll make sure to
say things in such a way
>> honestly, I I I think hang-ups around
university in this town it would would
make so much sense. I thought when Perry
was saying that [__] about him, that was
kind of like hitting the truth. That was
kind of hitting the truth.
It's like he wasn't like um
you know, I can't be bothered to lay out
the whole sketch or project. You know,
like [__]
his his her Nick was I can't be bothered
to do it. But I think Perry had like a
really good bit of age as well if I
remember correctly.
He used to write it. Nick was a loser
through Midland High School. When he got
accepted into his pride, he thought this
is going to be my turn, but he was the
piggy.
Yeah, that's good. That's good.
So you never get any
>> And it's like it's like a whole life of
chasing that approval.
It's why he makes these like bizarre
jokes and comments about women that make
him sound like like a you know
I I I shouldn't keep saying he sounds
like a rapist, but you know.
[__]
Dude. [laughter]
This is what he wants. He wants a little
proviso. This is not about Nicholas
DeOrio. Chud Logic chat, Nicholas DeOrio
is worried about you. Please don't give
him any [__]
Ple- Please don't hate lock his Discord
server. Holy [__] man.
If you mention a Sam Pepper or iDubbz,
then you're clearly talking about me to
99% of your audience.
Wow, that's interesting, isn't it?
>> The Archchad story legit almost makes
you feel bad for Nick. If If Nick didn't
lie about it on stream and [__]
afterwards,
I would almost feel bad for Nick cuz of
that that Archchad story. But because he
goes around just like
totally lying trying to cope about it,
it's like nah, actually.
Nicholas has banned so many people from
his chat that they've come to my chat
and now his audience is captured by my
chat and he's worried about my chat.
That's what's going on here. I spoke at
length about this today, which is true,
by the way. Add that story again. I got
Chad to cover this on Kick. I did I got
both Chad and Jace to cover this [__]
Where is it?
Let's pull it up. Let's do it for the
segment. Let's do it for the segment. I
forgot this was a seg- in a segment yet.
Okie's in the middle, and I think it's
DanTavious, the bearded man. So, this is
Nick telling a story from VidCon.
This is Nick's version. Then we're going
to see a different version, okay, guys?
This is very very key stuff here. on the
right, and I'm like, "Huh, what's
happening right now?" So, I'm [__] up.
I'm If I don't give a perfect rendition
of what they said, I apologize. But, it
starts off normal, and they're like,
"Dude, you got to let Give Bob Blacks a
break. Why are you still going after Bob
Blacks?" And I'm like, "Well, he tried
to get me into a fight with Technicals,
which could have [__] harmed my my If
I got locked into that, I could have
like not been making regular content.
That could harm me financially or
whatever by like lying about this
comment cop [__] He got me like fight
with all these different people from my
past all at once or whatever. It went
really well, but if it didn't, that
could have been a huge inconvenience for
me. So, like obviously, I'm going to
[__] on him more, right?"
>> Right. And then, I
>> Like, do you listen to even the way he
talks about stuff, man? It's so funny.
not been making regular content. That
could harm me financially or Give Bob
Blacks a break. Why are you still going
after Bob Blacks?" And I'm like, "Well,
he tried to get me into a fight with
Technicals, which could have [__]
harmed my my If I got locked into that,
I could have like not been making
regular content. That could harm me
financially or whatever by like lying
about this comment cop [__]
>> Like, dude,
he tried to get me into a fight with
Technicals.
Well, he tried to get me into a fight
with Technicals, which could have
[__] harmed my my If I got locked
into that,
>> Which could have harmed my If I not been
making regular content. I could have not
been making regular content.
What, you're saying that you would have
to take a break from streaming if you
got into a fight with Technicals, or
you're saying that the Technicals
content would take over your main
content?
You know, you can just you know, quickly
respond and then go back to your main
content, right? You can just keep doing
that. Like, the way he frames and talks
about everything, it's like
so bizarre.
Well, I I I had to I had to go really
hard on Bo black cuz he was he was
causing me risk. He was causing me risk.
Huh? Bo black was causing you risk?
What?
content that can harm me financially or
whatever by like lying about this
comment cop [__] He got me like fight
with all these different people from my
past all at once or whatever. It went
really well, but if it didn't that could
have been a huge inconvenience on me. So
like obviously I'm going to [__] on him
more, right? Right.
>> And then they start like progressively
getting weirder about it until Okie just
pulled ahead of Like like this is the
thing man is Tom on one hand
tries to act
and kind of hangs around with people
that are a bit more, you know,
And we'll talk about Brandon Buckingham
when we get to that segment in the next
few days, but um
you know, for all the negative I'll say
about Brandon Buckingham
he's like kind of a
more
real
kind of offline person.
And I feel like Tom tries to lean that
way and tries to hang out with a lot of
people like that.
But then he also treats Nick
like he's not being
a to-
a totally insane
pathetic weirdo here.
And it doesn't make a lot of sense cuz
how are you
both like
living any kind of real life and hearing
Nick talk like this and not being like
audibly disgusted by it.
Do you know what I mean? Like if you're
going if you're
If you have friends
and go to parties
and [__] like that.
I I can't imagine that you just get into
a Discord call with Nick and hear him
going, "Oh, well, the thing is he got me
to fight with all these people from my
past and it could have gone really bad
for me, but it didn't. So I guess it was
fine, but that's why I had to go really
hard on Bo black."
How did your listening go? Really? You
had to go that really hard on this guy
because he was
spazzing out in your DMs talking about
how he wants to kill himself over you
going on a panel with Destiny and he's
like wearing a dress and sending you
video
vlogs about his gender journey. You had
to
That was like a
a risk to you. That was like
That was like a big fight. That was like
a big challenge.
That sounds kind of bizarre.
What do you mean? That sounds insane.
normal interaction with Pryor than the
same day where he's like, "Oh, dude, we
should box." Remember we wanted to talk
about boxing? Same day, normal
interaction when he wasn't drunk. Then
he goes, "You're just [__] You're
like a bully."
>> Cuz he knows Nick will have a meltdown.
Yeah, well, I feel like Tom has to be
aware, though.
Like again, I don't like Tom a whole
lot, but I feel like Tom does like he is
more normal.
I know I know that to be true.
He is a bit more put together in terms
of
um
you know?
I guess acting his age, almost.
You know what I mean?
Like Nick does not act
29 or whatever he is.
Yeah, Nick acts like a middle school
girl.
Tom acts like a 20 early 20-year-old.
It's just very bizarre and he must see
that. He He must see that. I just can't
imagine he doesn't see that.
I don't know if he said bully, but he's
like, "You're on a power trip, man. You
have no power in your real life, okay?
And you take it out on Bob Blacks so you
can feel powerful for once in your
miserable life or something." And I'm
just like, "Whoa, what are you talking
[laughter] about?" He's so [__]
crazy. Truth, Nick. Like what's going on
right now? And then now at this point
Ghostgum kind of turns off and looks
Dude, Bob Blacks is kind of Bob Blacks
getting
Ghostgum turns off and starts talking to
somebody else. So now it's really just
the two of them talking to me. And then
all of a sudden, like, you know, they're
like going, "Oh, I tried to help Bob
Blacks. We're trying to get him in a
good direction and something." And I go,
"Well, let me stop you right there. I've
been giving this guy advice for years,
so now you're in my shoes. Can you tell
me if he's listening? And then one of
them goes, ah, you got me there, Nick,
or something like that. And I'm like,
listen, I'm not trying to [__] this guy
over. I thought this was like a
salvageable situation. Then all of a
sudden he goes, how would you feel if he
killed himself, Nick? And I'm like,
WHOA.
>> DAMN. WHOA.
>> THAT ESCALATED.
So I'm just staring at this guy. I like
like with a smile I'm like
is there going to be a punchline at the
end of this joke? Like what's happening
right now?
>> Is this Okie talking to you or the the
other dude? No, this is the Dantevius
Beard guy. He's like, how would you feel
>> Charlie, did you watch my argument with
Okie on Jace Tookus the other week?
Where um I'm like I keep arguing it down
with him and backing into a corner
basically trying to get him to say
Nick's like a total sensitive [__]
And he's like he's like, you're trying
to get me to say Nick's a total
sensitive [__] I I keep saying to I'm
saying to him like, well, no, you can
say actually the total opposite of that
if you believe it and can argue it. But
it sounds like you don't believe it and
you don't feel like you can argue it.
So yeah, if you don't if you can't argue
with what I'm saying and you don't
believe the inverse, then
shouldn't you agree? [laughter]
And he's like,
I can't remember what he said or what
his go around it was. Like, you
shouldn't fight with Nick.
He
>> [laughter]
>> if he killed himself.
And eventually I'm I'm just sitting here
just registering this is happening to me
right now. This is like the most awkward
[__] encounter of my entire life. And
I just start laughing. And I go like,
I'm I'm as advertised. Why the [__]
would I care if Josh dies?
What what what does that have to do with
me? What are we or at [__] VidCon
having a drinks? What are you doing?
This is weird. So they start like going
and I go, all right, hold on. So I put
my hand on Okie's shoulder and I I split
the two of them and I walk through them
and I go, maybe next time, you know,
have your friend come and fight his own
battles cuz this is really pathetic. But
uh
yeah, I feel like I got suicide baited
by proxy. But they actually admitted
that they left him at the hotel to come
to Tom's party. Like what kind of
friends are you?
>> Why they leave him? Because he I guess
he he either didn't want to go or he
wasn't invited.
So they're So on the big last night
party of VidCon, he sat in his hotel
room alone, I guess.
>> Oh, that's sad.
>> Because his friends went to go party
without him. And then they came over and
blamed me. Which is funny cuz I didn't
try to keep him out.
>> assessment of this. This is all Tom's
fault.
>> [laughter]
>> It probably is in some way, to be
honest. Tom, why didn't you invite
Bobby, dog?
>> Well, he unfollowed me on Twitter over
the over the weekend. So I assume that
he felt Oh, well then yeah, you can't
invite somebody unfollows you. Yeah,
you're right. Yeah, he felt jipped by
me. He broke the mutual.
>> Did you ever find out who the Canadian
Nick was? Like the Canadian Nick guy?
>> Yeah, he's I know him.
>> know who he is?
>> mesmerized by his dancing. All right,
here we go. So this is the real story
here. This is where we're really kicking
into it, okay? Nick guy? Yeah, he's I
know him. Do you know who he is?
>> mesmerized by his dancing.
Dude, immediately after this, I was
fuming I was fuming that that had just
happened. But immediately after this, I
go meet back up with Wavy and we're
standing there talking. And then all of
a sudden he goes, "Dude, that's the
guy." Apparently at the Canadian party
the day before, some guy was walking
around saying like, "Oh, my name's Nick.
I do politics, but I'm a good Nick, you
know? There's a lot of bad Nicks out
there giving us Nicks a bad name. Like
Nick Fuentes and Nick DiOrio, those
guys, awful. I'm a good Nick."
>> True. So he didn't realize he told like
all my friends that at the party. He's
in the same club. [laughter]
So I walked up to him but I introduced
myself. I go, "I'm the bad Nick."
>> VidCon does sound like hell and I
understand hearing stuff like this why
Aiden gets along so well there. that
you're saving everybody from. And he
goes, "What?" I go, "You know, you're
saving all these Nicks out there. I'm
the one that you're saving them from or
something." And he goes, "Oh, I'm not
shaking your hand."
>> [laughter]
>> He owned you. And then he No, but then
he gets right in my face and he goes, "I
don't like you." And it sounded like the
red guy from Smiling Friends and I just
started laughing.
>> This did not happen. I don't This is I
don't remember this.
>> No, there were witnesses. Ask Wavy,
there were witnesses. He's like, "I
don't like you." And I'm like, "Oh,
okay. [laughter]
So, wait, what are you going to do about
it?" And he's like
>> [laughter]
>> And I just called him a slur.
I'm like, "You're acting like a slur
right now."
>> [laughter]
>> So, he snatched my glasses off my face
and started dancing seductively at me.
So, I followed him for like 2 seconds
and I realized he's not Oh, it all
connects. And then I walked back.
He started aggressively dancing at me.
I've never seen so Dude, it was like
[__] West Side Story. It was weirdest
[__] I've ever seen. I thought I was in
a musical.
>> [laughter]
>> I literally thought I was in a [__]
musical. I was It was the most confusing
[__] thing I've ever seen. Dude, what
would you do if somebody starts
flamboyantly dancing aggressively
towards you, Tom? What would you do in
that situation?
>> I don't know. I don't know.
>> weirdest You know who this person is?
Dude, cuz I I've said this story on
stream and they still can't identify
like but they they still don't know who
this YouTuber is. Is this a streamer or
a YouTuber?
>> He's a YouTube guy. I just know him as
the flamboyant Nick from politics or
something. Dude, I literally was just
like I don't know do I What do I do?
Even in this story, the cracks are
showing, right? There's a little detail
about his glasses getting stolen. And to
anyone that's been in any kind of, you
know, social situation like that So,
wait.
The guy took his glasses off you and you
just let that happen. Like this guy just
came up to you.
He felt comfortable enough
to put his hands at your face.
You let him take something off of you.
And he started Yeah, like emoting at
you. That's That's coming across like
you got humiliated a little bit. That's
coming across like a
quite a humiliating moment for you that
this guy was disrespecting you like that
in public. So, the cracks are showing
even here as much as Nick is trying to
put a brave face on.
Who here Vega, what would you do if
somebody stole your glasses and then
seductively sat in front of [laughter]
you? I just called him a slur to his
face and I punched him after. I feel
like it's a hate crime.
>> What happened before him talking [__] or
I'm not going to shake your hand, which
is fair enough. I do that to people. I
say I don't like you, bro. I'm not going
to shake your hand.
>> comes back over and he goes,
"They're prescription. You can have them
back." I'm like, "Yeah, thanks for my
$600 glasses, asshole."
>> Yeah, but if you went if you went to go
like
Like, dude. My my $600 glasses. $600
dude. Take my glasses or
>> He's got like they were six. I just
That detail. Like you're saying that
like, "Oh, yeah. I'm so rich."
You let this guy take $600 glasses off
of you and run away with them.
You let him take
$600 glasses off of you and dance away
with them.
He did? Then he's just going to get
smacked, bro. That's not my fault. It's
your fault.
>> [laughter]
>> You got to understand I'm in like an
aura right now. Like the [__] bull
black suicide baiting [__] just happened
and then that happened. Oh, they
happened back to back?
>> It was back to back. I was fuming over
that. [laughter] That's why I was so
[__] mad. And I I got to and then all
of a sudden that happens and I'm like,
"Dude, we weren't the whole weekend."
And there was just and then all of a
sudden this [__] just goes down. It's
crazy. But otherwise, it was fantastic.
I have no other complaints about Yeah,
at your boy's
>> Anything that was funnier. I didn't know
most of this happened, to be honest.
Tom, did you have the did you have cops
and security there? Yeah, dude. Slacker.
We did not have security. We did have
somebody IDing at the door, though.
Oh, okay. Cuz Vega would used to be
security, but they actually upgraded to
Slacker TV. Slacker was security? Oh,
Slacker TV. I remember. Oh, I dude,
there was somebody there. I'm not going
to say who they were with, who like ran
and crashed into a giant wooden stick
and knocked down like an entire display
on my head.
>> Oh. Dude, [laughter]
dude, I literally it came crashing down.
It was and [__] landed on my head. I
was like, "Thank you so much. That was
like so awesome of you." You guys So,
this is the guy This is the guy that
Nick's talking about. This guy at the
altercation with, okay?
Let's just see quickly. What's this guy
like? Who is this guy? If it plays.
But surely it will. Surely YouTube won't
just be total aids and stop me.
But why why does it do this, man? It's
so [__] cancer. Why, man? Stock
image. I just I I'm
Oh oh to me packing plants and slaughter
house people, they just cut capacity
that is equivalent to 7 and 1/2% of your
entire country's ability to produce
beef. Take that in. 7 and 1/2% of your
entire slaughter house capacity and
packaging is gone. And I mean that does
sound bad, but don't worry. It's already
>> this isn't exactly the voice you
described, is it? I thought this guy's
got a pretty normal voice. I don't think
this guy's got like a nerd voice or
anything. priced in and by that I mean
they already were over capacity on
production ability by 13% post pandemic.
So really it doesn't actually change
[__] all right? They're just
rebalancing the market realities, okay?
But hey, at least heifer populations on
feedlots are down, which ah [__] Okay,
first off, heifers. Heifers are female
cows that have yet to conceive a calf.
And also I should really state that I do
use cow to mean all cows in the same way
Yeah, the act was stupid, but you know.
What you going
So yeah, let let's hear now another
telling of the story.
Good evening. Okay.
So here's a funny story.
VidCon, okay?
VidCon.
Turkey Tom's rager at VidCon.
I'm frozen.
Am I unfrozen? Cool.
Cool.
Turkey Tom's rager at VidCon.
So Tom threw a big party in this skate
uh like like this skate shop with this
indoor like mini ramp and like street
session set. It was like a warehouse for
a a skateboard brand.
>> guys are like in the the like little
Jreg orbit, okay?
Okay.
And
we're all there. So,
there's the commentary people. The
commentary people there.
And Nicholas De Orio shows up.
Okay, Nicholas De Orio shows up.
So,
Oki and Nicholas De Orio have beef.
Oki's weird stories and Nicholas De Orio
have a have a public beef and they have
for a long time.
So,
when I walk in,
uh Oki
and Dan Tavius are pressing
I don't like totally hate Jreg, but I I
do think a lot of his content kind of
sucks.
They're all still friends with Bo
Blacks.
And I've like I've talked about
>> hate the impact he's had on political
discussion, so.
The political compass [__] was already
pretty bad before Jreg, but he just
shed a light. Bo Blacks a few times.
Nice guy. It's totally [__] criminal.
That look, man.
Guy's [__] in his mid-20s. He wants
to cross-dress. Who gives a [__] okay?
If [__] Bo Blacks
I'll say Jared's dogs. I've only say I
used to say that deep. I used to say
that. I've moderated. I've moderated a
bit. I don't hate him that much.
cross-dress as an adult man. Look, he's
in the commentary sphere. He's going to
get dragged through the mud.
Uh and and he maybe he should have
expected to get dragged through the mud
for his uh for his online behavior with
the cross-dressing.
But who [__] cares? Who gives a [__]
okay? I don't give a goddamn. Anyway,
you have [__] Diorio
who this is all the all this guy [__]
talks about is this
this other man
and his his decisions in his adult life.
Okay? Dirtbag.
Dirtbag. It's all he [__] talks He's
always streams about his [__] Bobax
and why Bobax is a No, it's it's a
really important thing. It's really
important he's he's putting to risk. He
had to fight Bobax. So, Bobax is putting
his career at risk.
Dude. Making a lolcow out of [__]
Bobax.
Right?
So,
Okie who already doesn't like Diorio
>> It's total [__] by the way cuz Nick
was actually giddy about Bobax having
meltdowns for months beforehand. He was
actually teasing it and [__] you
know,
calls and [__]
And Jstark's [__] oil of EC after
stream being like, "Hey, oh my god, you
don't know how crazy Bobax was about
that palm tweet about the, you know,
the whole praise give with your parents
saying, "Oh, you didn't even know how
dude is so crazy dude is you literally
he was like giddy. He was desperate to
kill this guy.
Presses Diorio. He goes up and he goes
like, you know,
uh
Bobax is like really depressed.
Um how would you feel if like Bobax
killed himself? Like, you know, you're
basically like
you're you're you're you're basically
just you know, like cyberbullying this
guy into like [__] complete
depression over
>> Jstark did that right that there was one
time where
we're in a VC after stream and Destiny
joined
and Nick's like reporting everything
Bobax has said to him
some [__]
I vaguely I do vaguely remember that.
over nothing. Like, he didn't do
anything to you. He's just existing on
the [__] internet.
And then Net Loss
Net Loss walks up
and beefs Nicholas DeOrio.
So, he he walks up. I I see this all. I
didn't I wasn't uh I didn't talk to
DeOrio. I walked up to him.
I walked up to DeOrio.
And then I was like realized who it was
and I thought I don't want to talk to
this guy. I I don't even want to like
instigate uh with this dude.
So,
so I walk up realize that they're
talking to DeOrio and then I walk away.
Net Loss walks up behind me
and uh
tells DeOrio to his face he doesn't like
him.
And DeOrio is like
but DeOrio sticks his hand out to shake
Net Loss's hand and Net Loss says, "I'm
not shaking your hand. I don't like
you."
>> Royce, obvious. Like I you know, I can
do Bow Blax coverage. Chad can do Bow
Blax coverage.
It's disingenuous when Nick does Bow
Blax coverage, when Bow Blax has been
the same way the same time except now he
puts on a dress.
The same way the whole time.
And the only thing that changed is um
he
sided with King Nothing or some [__]
Just that cried about it.
And then takes DeOrio's sunglasses off
of his face. By the way, look.
DeOrio is a short fat [__] okay?
DeOrio is a short fat [__] He's like
5'6" maybe and he's very big.
>> [snorts]
[clears throat]
>> And so DeOrio
Net Loss takes the sunglasses off
DeOrio's face and puts them on
and then starts dancing away.
And and and dances and like DeOrio goes
to like chase him but like he can't
chase him. So, Nick just like has his
sunglasses on and dances away. Anyway,
DeOrio has told the story like
uh two or three times on stream and he
keeps characterizing Net Loss
as like I'm sure people in the chat have
seen Net Loss's videos.
Um he keeps characterizing Net Loss as
like a tiny
uh geeky guy and he's like, "Oh, this
tiny guy
this tiny guy game came up to me. He was
like, 'You're a Nicholas DeOrio. I don't
like you.'" Which is not what which is
not what Net Loss sounds like at all. If
you've seen his videos, he has a deeper
voice than me.
And he's as tall as me. We're both like
6 ft tall.
So, just the fact that like DeOrio keeps
telling this story
on his streams
and also
is um
you know, characterizing Net Loss as as
like a as a as a character that he's
like not at all and anybody who knows
him or seen his videos can like clearly
clearly disprove any of the
characterizations that uh
that DeOrio has given Net Loss is
[__] hilarious. And also every time
DeOrio has told this story
every time DeOrio has told this story
>> This guy's voice is definitely deeper
than Net Loss's. All right, that's
that's not true.
He says that he called Net Loss a
which he didn't do.
>> Woah, I'm on Twitch. I'm on Twitch. I'm
on Twitch. That's terrible.
Bad
bad word. I think he says it again, so
I'm going to end my Twitch stream.
He's No, sorry. He said he said, "I
called him iDubbbz's favorite slur." So,
I don't know if that's
or [clears throat] or
Yeah.
But he keeps saying that he called Net
Loss a slur, which he didn't. Like he
didn't call him a slur. He's like
telling this story as if like, "Oh,
this tiny guy walked up to me and was
really geeky and annoying and then I
then I called him the N-word."
I just
Is this the annoying
Why would you lie about calling someone
a slur? Because he wants to be edgy.
Because he's like, "Oh, I have to be
This is cool. This my my perception of
being cool
is uh
Yeah, he talked about this on the
Half-Baked podcast. No, it's really
funny.
Cuz his perception of being cool is
being like this tough Long Island dude
who uh
you know, wears a Rolex
and uh and talks about um
He's like, "My $600 sunglasses."
All right, he's just his his perception
of being cool is just being this edgy
Long Island dude who calls people the
N-word. [laughter]
And in actuality, he's a short, fat [__]
who who's bullying his old friends into
like suicide.
God, what a [__] abhorrent person,
man. I don't know, it's so crazy that
it's uh it's it's so crazy that you can
uh
the slur-slinging LARPer.
It's too funny to not even have the
balls to say the slur. I know, man.
Like, you're hanging out like Turkey Tom
is there.
I don't No one there gives a [__] Half
of them are [__] commentary
YouTubers. You think if you say you're
going to get in trouble at the [__]
at the uh at the commentary language.
Bad word. Bad word.
Anyway, funny as [__] Look, I feel like
I feel like people stay people say stay
close to him cuz he's a demon.
Cuz I know he's friends with uh he's
friends with like Wavy Web Surf
and uh
Tom and some of those other people. And
like
I understand why you would want him why
you wouldn't want him as an enemy.
Uh because he will like unapologetically
uh you know, double-cross you
any second he gets, right? If it be If
it can become content, he will do it.
And I feel like you need to be in a
position like like um Web Surf and Tom
are like much bigger YouTubers than him,
and it's advantageous for him to
to stay in in their good graces and vice
versa.
Um, so I don't know. I get it. I get why
they're friends. I don't judge them for
that. It's just like
that uh that that guy is so [__]
funny.
It's so I don't know, man. It's just
such a funny stupid [__] story.
I just keep hearing it, which is
hilarious, too, cuz um
that law like
his channel's still so small and the
fact he's like living rent-free in
Nicholas Deorio's head.
I am keto is goated. I've been in a
great [__] mood. No drinking and
keto. I have been in an amazing [__]
mood.
The past uh
the past 2 weeks. I'm
Yeah, I think that's the story. So,
yeah. Obviously, a bit different than
Nick's telling that. A little bit
different than Nick's telling that.
So, that's why I think we're doing. Bro,
you're so sensitive. I said you might
talk about it. The problem is people
don't care if these guys sweep and never
call them out. So, so it also
I do want to apologize to Augie,
actually. Augie,
I am sorry you're having to do this.
And to be honest with you, I'm sorry to
the everyone else in the group chat,
okay? I don't want to have to do this,
but my hand has been forced. I figure we
get everything on the table, then
everything's out in the open. The
problem is people don't care if these
guys sweep and never call them out for
that kind of stuff at all. Whereas, me
and Nick historically get endless [__]
for sweeping. So, I don't blame Nick for
integrating your callouts being directed
at him and me. You see You see the
problem here with Augie, bro? He's
having to like prop up Nicholas's
astronic behavior because he knows what
the consequences are if he goes too far
against him. It's so obvious, bro.
It's so obvious [laughter] thing.
>> [snorts]
>> Nobody thinks he's talking about a
Cheeto.
And if you want to draw that
distinction,
you should be more clear interpreting.
Also, Augie, if you have an issue with
me mentioning you're away, I apologize.
I was just highlighting that you weren't
around to talk right now.
I don't.
Okay, then why isn't it bringing it up?
I said that because he's talking about
the cabal not covering it, but
mentioning Augie's away. Oh, no,
Nicholas might be getting more [__]
because I mentioned Augie's away. Do you
see the insanity here, bro? He just is
so desperate to like not be in any sort
of limelight with this. Even the fact
I've mentioned that Augie's away,
apparently, is some terrible thing. When
the reason I'm saying it is to say, "To
be fair to Augie, he's not here at the
moment. He said he's going to cover it
when he's back." That's the whole point
of me saying that. I don't know, but I
wasn't bothered about that. Just
supporting that your vague posting is
just directing more
>> so catty. It's just like what's it even
like saying as the first cuz it's like
they've had the argument in DMs.
And then Nick has gone to the group chat
to start the argument again so that he
can have
all these other like cronies like
[__] Zylae chipping in.
It's so shameful.
[__] at me, someone who quite literally
isn't skipping a stream to cover it.
Dude, he is so bothered about getting
[__] And here's the problem, Nicholas.
It's not just me. I said the big sweet
might be on, okay?
Meanwhile, Kiwi Farms is calling him
some [__] sweeper, okay?
You've got all of the anti-commentary
people that are floating about. They're
getting into the mix. They're calling
him a sweeper. All the kind of
technicals era people are talking about,
you know, the double standards stuff.
You know, people are getting the boot
in. It's not just from me, and it's not
just from my community. But because I'm
making other points about people not
picking the story up, it becomes all my
[__] problem, dude. I just hope
you can at least see
how [__] hard this is to deal with
this guy, man. I will say it's totally
embarrassing and annoying dealing with
the [__] retards that come in every
time and go Who's Zaptie? Zaptie?
Zaptie? Zaptie?
I don't want to [__] I literally do
not give a [__] about Zaptie. I never
want to hear someone
bring that up as a criticism and like
It's just like so [__] pointless. Who
gives a [__]
I'm the problem apparently and this is
what you're dealing with behind the
scenes. Some shitty [__] posted I was
taking a shot at you on your gay
subreddit.
I literally looked and saw no videos
other than mine about it apart from the
[__] It's nuts.
I was referenced in the YouTube drama
post as the coverage. I feel like I'm
going insane. Maybe you should be a bit
less sensitive when all these chatters
send you on a one comment death spiral.
Oh my [__] god, dude. Oh my god.
I'm the sensitive one apparently.
What's he's in here again? Argued about
this again. Hypersensitive about being
referred to at every [__] stage. I've
made comments on stream talking about
the status of where you guys are on what
you said cuz bear in mind by this point
I have streamed I think on Kick and I
said Augie's going to talk about it and
Nick said he's going to talk about it.
I've made comments on stream talking
about the status of where you guys are
on what we have said.
I looked this morning at what videos
were out and it was mine and [__]
CamNuggets then I posted that. I knew
that you were both possibly going to
cover it.
I knew that you were both possibly So,
this is genuine. I'm genuinely saying
that was about these other [__] not
covering it. I know you guys are going
to cover it or possibly going to cover
it so I'm talking about them now.
But they're still finding a way to bring
it back round to themselves. It's so
obnoxious, bro.
>> Yeah, I I I literally barely bring
myself to have
uh positive or neutral conversations
with people in DMs.
I cannot
be doing with like arguing [__] down in
DMs. If I end up in a voice chat with
someone off stream and I get the chance
to press them about something that I
screwed them on,
I do that.
Because it's just much easier to talk.
But the idea that you're going to argue
[__] down in DMs is crazy.
It's not happening.
Just not happening.
Why do you think so few people have
covered it? The story is just forming.
You started talking about the big sweep
in your stream on Thursday morning after
the allegation showed up Wednesday
night. I was talking about the big sweep
might be on. These things take a while
to take root. Glad you cleared it up
half-assed today though. Oh my god,
dude. Give me a [__] break with that
[__] These daily commentary channels
pump out slop.
Dude, do you know what I love about
this? Nicholas releasing DMs that show
nothing.
Oh, so based. So cool king. Well done.
Me releasing DMs further showing what a
pathetic, sensitive coward this guy is.
Oh, this is a nothing burger. This is
total nothing burger. This is just
embarrassing for you as he sat there
quivering in chat moaning about my
community. Give me a [__] break with
that [__] These daily commentary
channels pump out slop.
Daily commentary talks about KSI and
Logan Paul. Who is doing daily Kiwi
Farms slop or making any content that
this would fall into the usual docket?
So I use more Pegasus as an example,
okay?
This is what I'm talking about, man.
What ties does Pegasus have to Tom that
he would not end up covering this? What
incentive does he have to sweep? So this
gets into the kind of intricacies of it,
okay? And it could be and me and Augie
talked about this, right? It could be
that maybe it's too profitable talking
about Asan and iDubbz, okay? So maybe
that's the reason it doesn't get spoken
about. But then it still is not bringing
attention to an allegation, which again,
not saying Tom's guilty,
but the nature of that dynamic means
that it doesn't end up getting spoken
about, right? It could be that they're
friends with him. It could be they're
friends behind the scenes. Fun rate.
Here's the thing, right? You need to
look at the way that the response was
dealt with to see that I was correct.
Everyone was on the [__] response.
>> You know what would have been more fun
than reading it, Keem? Watching it on a
live stream. Like white on rice.
Everyone was within like a day. Everyone
was on top of it. Even people that
didn't cover the allegations originally.
There's nothing wrong with making
content allegations as long as you
notice it is an evolving story. Yeah,
exactly. I would say if commentary
people are not covering it by tomorrow,
then I think you could give some sweet
criticism, but isn't all this like brand
new? Gets ignored, obviously.
>> [snorts]
>> Don't worry, mate. It's just banter, in
it?
>> [laughter]
>> This guy is so pressed, bro.
Ha! Yeah, you guys can't take a bit of
banter.
Okay?
And then,
and then, all he says, "Look at this.
Isn't this Isn't this crazy?" By the
way, I'm more than happy to expand on
this when we talk on stream.
So, we'd already arranged to talk on
stream.
Fair's fair.
Yeah, yeah, sure, man. Sounds good. Like
look at the difference, bro. Me and
Augie were also going at it. I will not
leak, obviously, my own DMs with Augie.
I feel a little bit bad about giving
them here. But Augie has been more than
reasonable in this, okay? Um I watched
half of Kam on his video, Connor
dropping. So, I was going to watch that
and then maybe score the dot myself to
get filled in. Also, man, you have to
appreciate that there are a lot of
There's a lot of hate coming your way.
Uh already, people are jumping off my
tweet to mention you, like Alberto,
who's not even in my community.
So, I noticed that people like Michael
Alberto were kind of commenting on the
post.
And um
it's like Michael Alberto isn't really
from my community.
It's not like he's in my chat. It's not
like he watches my streams, but there's
like this kind of anti-commentary
like people that are also sniffing about
this, you know? And just to be clear, I
don't have like a massive beef with
Michael Alberto, right? I'm just using
him as an example. You know, this is not
said with any malice. I'm not saying
this is like, you know, it's just you
just Look, there's other people that
really don't like you that are also
jumping off of this.
And he's like trying to make out like
it's all me, you know?
Look at this as well, dude. Look at
this, too. You seriously telling me that
it isn't wild that 48 hours after one of
the biggest commentary guys allegations
that dropped that all over Twitter there
isn't a single large channel talking
about this.
Who do you think I'm talking about here?
Am I talking about Nicholas, or am I
talking broadly? Am I talking about Is
it not crazy that there's no big channel
talking about this? And what does
Nicholas do? What does Nicholas do?
Makes it all about himself again, bro.
All about himself again. [laughter] It's
Yeah, see, here's the thing. On On one
hand, it's like I do totally believe,
and I've said this many times, Chad's
initial statement is like about Nick.
Basically, like almost entirely. Like at
least 80%.
Um
But when he's arguing this down,
statements like this, this is obviously
basically a walk back.
But Nick is like not accepting it. Nick
is like, you know,
Chad's saying, "All right, you're going
to cover it. You're going to cover it.
That 20% is still there, though. That
20% that I was saying is still there."
You're saying you're going to cover it,
cool.
But that I still stand by that 20%. And
Nick is like, "I'm going to cover it.
I'm going to cover it." He's like So I
was like,
Like Okay, yeah, we know. We We know.
But he wants Chad to I think what he's
trying to get here He's not saying it
directly. And he he has kind of said it
directly before.
He wants Chad to basically come out and
say,
"Nick's going to cover it.
I'm only talking about sensitive
society. Guys, leave Nick alone. Leave
Nick alone, everyone.
He wants that, basically. He wants Chad
to go out and give like an
order to stand down.
Like the it's to defend him from the
from the people attacking him.
Wednesday evening is not 48 hours.
Even if I covered it yesterday on my day
on my off day, my video wouldn't until
Sunday after E Fap Saturday.
Dude, I'm not talking about you. I mean
broadly.
I mean broadly.
Because I'm talking broadly. I
understand Nicholas has not covered it
yet cuz he's a streamer. The Daily Slop
channels, it takes an hour, 2 hours to
make a video and they've not got a video
out yet. Isn't that weird? Isn't that
odd? Isn't that a bit bizarre?
But no, Nicholas wants to make it about
himself again cuz of his [__] victim
complex. Holy [__] I'm talking about
the Daily Commentary channels.
>> [laughter]
>> As an answer to your question, the
reason the Daily guys aren't posting is
cuz one person hasn't researched it yet.
All those guys steal from each other.
Once a video's dropped, it cascades.
Yeah, and people don't want to go near
it because it's Turkey Tom.
Fair enough comment, I think. Dude, I
even said I have some sympathy for not
wanting to light your friend up. It
feels like you were looking at all the
takes and most provocative clips and
thinking it is all about you. I was fair
to lean on the meme. I did take some
shots at you and did talk about the
cabal and I won't deny that.
I think you've dove feet first and over
committed.
A position, mind you, I may have even I
may have even agreed with you on.
So, he's even saying here he would have
agreed with me.
But because I said in relation to him
the big sweep might be on is Bridge Burn
time. [__] you, dude.
Bro, I never said I wasn't taking shots
at Nick. I made some comments talking
about the big sweep might be on, and
Nicholas ended up covering it.
Whether or not he was going to
definitively is up for debate, of
course, okay?
You can't open up with the great sweep
on day one, lol. You're supposed to see
if they sweep first. Yes, hence why I
said, "Look at who covers this and who
doesn't."
So, Nicholas thinks that because I said
it's about him, it's only about him.
"Look at who covers this and who
doesn't" applies to multiple people. Who
covers it and who doesn't? And again,
he's trying to make it about himself.
Who was that specifically a jab at
everyone or me?
Okay?
Right?
So, because I've said to him it was
about him,
he wants to make it that's all about
him.
When it's who does and doesn't talk
about this. It's so obvious, bro.
"Everything I ever say is about you and
you alone."
>> [laughter]
>> So, was that not intended to be about to
be about a jab at me, just for
clarification? Yes, I mean, based on the
fact you have swerved over topics, I was
somewhat thinking of you, but you were
covering it, so I guess not. And this is
the thing, dude. This is the thing.
The reason Nick felt so called out by
the comment is because he wasn't sure
whether he was going to talk about it.
So, I'm saying here, "Well, you are
talking about it, so it doesn't apply to
you, does it?" But it did apply to him,
and then he decided to cover it, so it
doesn't apply to him, and he wants to
act upset that I even dared suggest it
might be on. It's so [__] obvious,
dude.
I was I was just looking for yes or no,
not really interested in the back story.
>> [snorts]
>> Also,
Al Gear OC, [__] you. I'm not sucking
myself off of how brave I am.
Dude, it feels like I am insane. If this
was a Sargon 20 videos by now. I'm like,
bro,
>> [laughter]
>> AM I CRAZY HERE?
IT'S JUST TRUE. You know this is true.
It's easy money, but because he's a it's
a commentary golden boy, radio silence
from all these channels.
Yeah, see Sorn is easy money, but
covering Tom is more difficult, hence
why the only large channel who'll do it.
Bro, [__] off. I'm not saying I'm the
large channel. So, commentary broadly is
just totally compromised and
Dude, you're the only one who will brave
the wilderness and expose Tom Steen.
Drunk over here will like the way.
Dude, I love Augie. And then what this
Nick says?
Wow.
It looks like Nicholas is being friendly
back. Would you believe it? I appreciate
you guys taking Aiden right before he
imploded. That saved me another round of
this, lol.
And we have a little bit of, you know,
friendly camaraderie over this. By the
way, when Aiden watches this and he sees
that, get ready for a 20-minute tangent
because he was referenced once, by the
way, okay? Haha, man, that was funny.
Honestly, [__] himself over getting so
deep into ACC drama. I can agree there.
Wow.
Look at that. We're We're I'd say this
is a Like they said there, I appreciate
you guys taking Aiden right before he
exploded. It saved me another round of
this, lol. It's like so
Like what do you mean, man?
What the [__] are you talking about? I
probably spent you know, I I probably
interacted with Aiden
more than probably any other streamer
during that
in terms of content stuff. Obviously, I
I I think maybe I hung out with Dick as
more. I don't I don't I don't
in real life and [__] But in terms of
like content stuff around that
week or two long crash out, I probably
interacted with Aiden more than like
anyone else.
And he didn't cause me any problems.
It's like never a problem.
It's like such a neurotic mindset that
Nick seems to hold.
Where it's like, "Oh my god Oh my god,
this this drama going on around me. I
can't I can't take it. I can't deal with
this."
It's like such a It's like literally
like uh
You know, he does come off like a Jew
always.
He does It's very
>> [laughter]
>> It's It's very neurotic. It's just very
you know,
It's very Jewish stereotype. It's a very
hand-wringing in his hands, you know? I
mean,
all all
My my my money my my bottom line.
Wringing his hands.
Kvetching.
It's a bit friendly, wouldn't you?
Would you expect Guys, let me ask you
this.
Would you expect Yes, we've had an
argument. I'm going to talk to Augie.
Nick doesn't want to talk, whatever. But
we've had a bit of a back and forth
about it, right? Would you expect off
the back there to still be unspoken
resentment that it reveals itself when
you go on holiday? Like, what?
Things are like quite friendly at this
point.
But apparently, I need to get [__]
wrecked when I go away.
Well, I can agree there.
And we even reference it here.
Jud's getting nervous.
He's seeing visions of his chat watching
him engage in light banter with Fatty.
Age play, domestic violence, and
recording without consent is my current
list from a non-starter perspective.
That's my short list of stuff he needs
to address pending when I actually read
the rest on stream.
Be interesting to see what uh Nicholas's
thoughts were on Tom's response to the
age play, which is about 3 minutes long
and was just a message saying uh yeah,
he didn't do that actually from a person
that maybe doesn't want to even admit
they're doing age play stuff. But
whatever, I digress. We don't need to
get into that, okay?
I hope he isn't Anthony patting in a
diaper.
Yeah, I don't know if I draw the line at
wearing a diaper, but he'd be an F slur
for all of time if that were the case. I
think that's all the gay meme. So, I
don't know if I saw I don't know if you
saw the thread of the time they were
talking about diaper.
>> No, I saw a very compelling image of
time in a diaper. Cuz yeah, but that
just looks like it's humor or something.
The clip of us talking about him being
into age play [__] killed me.
Dude, I did a great bit about him being
Epstein. Haha. It does look rough now,
but there is no way anyone took that
seriously. Time, jeez, well, I feel bad
for him being my friend and all. If all
this story ends up amounting to an
unproven allegation and he got totally
[__] and these girls seem like pieces
of [__] to me regardless of what he did.
But that might be my sweep.
And then guys,
once again,
>> [sighs]
>> Chad
is too nice. Chad is fair. I don't know
what you want to say about this.
Bro, [__] off. In my coverage I said
this [__] I was legit fair. I wasn't
doing the Keemstar Keemstar [__] While
I played everything up.
Yes, PPP. Yes, Andy Warski. You're a
couple of [__] shock jocks. Constant
I've heard that Nick refers to himself
like Keemstar Keemstar. He thinks he's
he tries to say he's like that.
He's like that. He's not like
a reporter, you know. He's not telling
you the news in drama. He's telling you
He's doing wacky crazy lying.
That's what I've heard.
Literally [__] boosted shop to crazy.
>> Authier said that, but Nick said that.
That was a guy. But listen, I'm running
out of allies as it is, so we'll leave
it there. Maybe a guest appearance one
day. I don't know. Who knows, okay?
People said I was sweeping during my
coverage. That's why I had to pass that
on to you guys to take the heat off me.
And then I say,
also, beyond the drama and [__] talking
and arguing, I know what it's like to
have an embarrassing [__] leak. It
[__] sucks. So, I do hope on a
personal level he is doing okay.
So, I even give
a little bit of grace to say, "Hey,
I know it [__] sucks and I hope he's
doing okay."
Which makes it all the more [__]
insane that these [__] Well, this
loser
is desperately trying to paint me as
some sort of terrible, horrible snake
person where I'm covering the
allegations fairly. And then when I get
an opportunity privately, I say, "Yeah,
it [__] sucks. It [__] sucks. I
get it." He needs to stop [__] age
regress BPD [__] though. And you know,
it kind of it kind of more or less ends
from there. That's more or less the end
of it, okay? I hope you can at least
start to understand
why when this is how it was left
we had a disagreement again, got to a
sort of amicable place, right? 2 weeks
go by after this roughly. I go on
holiday.
Tom drops the response and Nicholas goes
on the attack against me.
Why not back then? Why not do it here?
Because Nicholas wanted to do it at a
time when he thought I wasn't going to
respond instantly
because he doesn't want the smoke. And
then
I come back and I respond, I release a
few DMs, he releases a few more to try
to make me look bad.
>> [clears throat]
>> And I mean, look, make your mind up
about this all you want. I think this
just shows Yeah, they have this combo
and yeah, and they glide and say that
Chud is pushing allegations as true.
It's just obviously not the case.
Wow.
Delayed coverage there.
I honestly
you know, I don't really
have any thoughts on this. I just It's
such a lame fallout. It's over such a
lame reason.
Like, "Oh, Chud said you were sleeping
and you [__] cried about it."
I care about Nick's
uh
awful, horrendous
uh lies and
betrayals of
principles he's spent his whole career
supporting.
That's what I care about.
I don't really care about uh uh
his friendship with Chad.
I don't care about the Tom stuff,
either, to be honest. I just don't, you
know. It's over It's over a lame reason.
It's over It's over coal.
It's over coal.
Coal bridge [music] burn.